yes we're with bobby and fabi this day
maybe could have gone a little bit
better but not much how do you feel
about how you performed today
yeah i i i thought you were going to say
could have gotten worse
because i mean in this game i was i was
rather lucky uh he he made a one-move
blunder you mean your last game against
jeffrey yeah against jeffrey i mean i
think the previous game was a
high quality one against the quantum i
was quite happy with that
um
but yeah overall it's uh it's a great
start for me
you have to feel like you didn't start
off the grandchild tour very well and
it's not tremendous motivation to win
the tour but
you still have to play the games and
want to win the tournament yeah
well yeah i mean i i don't have a chance
in the tour at anything but um
but in these tournaments i still want to
play well there's still
a lot at stake not only in terms of you
know ranking but also in terms of trying
to play
to play high quality chess if i can
that's um
i i mean at this point i'm you know i i
don't have high expectations i just want
to play play well because it's been a
while for me
you talk about ranking
people are debating whether you're
second or third in the world you
certainly have dropped below 2800 in the
live rankings how much motivation do you
have to get back to where we know uh
fabiano caruana belongs
yeah i mean i i think it's uh a surprise
i'm even
number two slash three because i mean
the way i've played over the past i
don't know
five months
i don't even deserve that ranking
um
but yeah i mean i had i had a high
rating and it kind of gradually
gradually fell
but hopefully i can i can start to
improve that all right well thanks very
much for joining us and good luck in the
rest of the games thank you
thank you